y realiza las transformaciones para
intentar hacer que esta figura móvil
coincida con efe y s
que es esta figura efe y ese h
me parece un pescadito por cierto
tenemos estas herramientas trasladadas
rotar reflejar y deshacer vamos a
trasladar para acercar la figura lo más
que se pueda a la que quiero ver si es
congruente o no muy bien hay parece que
están dando un besito de entrada veo que
este azul parece un poquito más alto o
más ancho que éste pero no vamos a
obviar nada vamos a usar la herramienta
para reflejar de manera que tratemos de
que coincidan estos elementos o estos
puntos de nuestra figura móvil con estos
puntos de acá le decimos reflejar
refleja y nos damos cuenta que aunque
hay algunos segmentos que si coinciden
perfectamente el f y el s no coinciden
con nuestra figura azul este punto de
hecho es el que no coincide y ocasiona
que estos dos segmentos no coincidan por
lo tanto aunque se parecen no son
congruentes decimos que no
y comprobar la respuesta en efecto no
son congruentes